good afternoon everybody
i see mrs coot is waiting to be admitted
okay welcome to july 5 infrastructure
services committee meeting um i'd like
to welcome
those public gallery and the press
those we have on zoom
first
i'm going to start with apologies um the
only apology i have is is worship
the mayor can i please
have someone move that except thank you
councillor arnold second
ms could and i'll put that motion all
those in favor
that against that is carried
uh takes me on to now declarations of
interest
uh do i have any for today
yes councillor clark yeah
raise the point of water i think we have
a
a member in this chamber who's just a
bit closer to the mic oh sorry
just want to raise an issue
around in this
table not con i'm not confirming a
conflict of interest
so uh councillor munsten has been on
facebook recently
and promoted uh what i would concern to
be some derogatory marks against the
groundswell group
which have engineered a large petition
to council which was received a couple
of weeks ago
and precedes the notice of motion that
i've got in today and i think it's
appropriate that she withdraw from that
participation
and to not do so would put us at a
reputational risk
and and so that people know that i'm not
begging off or um
playing politics here i respect that all
elected members have a right to a
personal view and also having a right to
express a view on other people's views
what is unfortunate in the facebook post
by the member
was that there was some discrediting of
the groundswell group and quotations and
i quote
quoting them as agitators who are using
co-governance as a weapon to drive hate
anger and fear
she adds to that that the people are
old-fashioned and have derogatory views
about women and undoubtedly other
members of the community who don't fit
their conservative worldview
and then finally adds
obvious that some candidates including
elected members are aligning themselves
with this groundswell group which might
focus on three waters but includes
climate change deniers
those against honoring the treaty and
holding conservative views about women
the rainbow community and ethnic
migrants minorities
as councils we have a charter that
commits us to having respect for
everybody and everybody's voice
at a time when we are wondering why
ratepayers don't submit in large numbers
or that we struggle to get people to
stand in local body elections
i think it's inappropriate to make those
sort of comments on a personal basis
it is my view that councillor munster's
bias towards this group publicly stated
on her facebook page precludes her
participation on the issue of the notice
of motion and i call on her to withdraw
and declare a conflict of interest okay
understanding orders neither the chair
nor the committee
can make a ruling on non-pecuniary
conflicts but
as uh
as a right of respect i'll council
manson would you like to reply
thanks chair
um
my comments would be that my facebook
post spoke to my experiences with the
groundswell people not only at the
meeting held on the 9th of june in
invercargill but previous meetings that
i have been part of around the region
uh i would also speak to the fact that
many of the people who have signed the
petition are not invocable ratepayers or
residents therefore
their
opinion
is not for me to
be responsible for
and finally i would say that the notice
of motion is actually nothing to do with
the petition that was provided by the
groundswell people because their
petition asked for
a binding referendum to be held by this
council and for us to no longer fund
or be a member of lgnz in this notice of
motion is about
uh joining the communities for local
democracy group which was not the
subject of their participation
so i don't deem that i have a conflict
okay that is noted council clerk and
thank you for the reply
the next thing is public forum
there was going to be
a spot assigned that was requested by me
as chair
for dan gordon the mayor of waimakariri
to
speak in relevance to
item five
but
because of complications and him
speaking
after talking with dan he has
not speaking today
so that is unfortunate but
i'm just advising the committee on that
also
a note here from
the chief executive and it's about face
masks so look for those people in the
public gallery unfortunately this room
is designated under the settings of
covert
a place where
uh face masks are required
now
um if it's
i'm sure we may be able to provide them
we we would have them if if you want to
put the hand up we can go and get them
for you
um we're not trying to kick you out um
so i had a nod from
so is that okay if we can get some face
masks
exempt
okay and anyone would like a face mask
we can grab it for them
we'd love you all to stay it's just one
of the unfortunate rules you'll see
counsellors wearing them
well
so exemptions those not wearing
fair enough
thank you i'm satisfied with that
right let's uh
move on first item is the minutes of the
infrastructural services committee held
on december 7th of june
thank you
second day
oh sorry sorry just some clarification
around the announcement you made about
the complications of
dan gordon not presenting um it was my
understanding that he was to
um present
and and clarify
rightly or wrongly it's not him
withdrawing from that
um
like to know why we are no longer
hearing from him given that anybody has
any dealings with with dan would know
he's a really neat and a really upfront
sort of guy he's um been through a
process where he actually consulted with
the committee uh when the minister was
telling us not to and got some
interesting results and feedback and i
would have liked to have heard from him
so i'd sort of like to understand who's
driving the um
the back off i guess of him being
involved in our in our presentation
which i thought was a really proactive
move on your behalf
yeah no it's a it's an interesting point
uh thank you for raising it council
clerk uh
look at
it actually uh came about uh i was
talking to logan sabri um over another
matter and and said that he would be
speaking today and hence appeared a nice
article on dan
um and since that article it's obviously
caught the eye of a few people in the
south island and in new zealand
and i've had emails um from people
wanting to
well insisting that they had the right
to join and speak
as well now that was not the purpose of
inviting dan
dan's intention was to provide clarity
around
the communities for local democracy
and he was invited on my request he did
not um put in a
request to speak at local
at public forum
um look it became
it just became
too
uncomfortable
to accommodate or not accommodate people
so after a discussion with dan uh we
both agreed that to
um
basically to keep the peace and and and
and not have anyone cry foul
um we decided that dan would not speak
so unfortunately that's the way it is
yeah
just a reflection for your chair i think
uh appreciate the fact that you've gone
down the path that you went down
i think it's uh
incumbent on us to hear the voice of an
alternative group
and hear it from the front line we've
heard any amount from the brian
cardogans of this world that are all in
favor of joining
the three waters process but the letter
that we wrote to the minister
back in september last year was quite
clear that this council was very much
not in favor of joining the three waters
and i would have liked to have heard
from him so i appreciate the work that
you've done
and it certainly no end that people
outside this council have stuck their
all into it
and and upset that uh process so point
of order mr chair i think we don't need
to go into a forensic exercise here you
have declared that there is not going to
be a public forum speaker
from the point of view of council that
is the end of the matter
um
like i appreciate the point of order but
i also appreciate council like clark's
comments
so
taking that um we were we on the um we
had a mover in a second
i think there was a second just
somewhere yes um
let's cook yeah
okay
so that's to receive those minutes so
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor
against they are carried
now we
look before we move on to the notice
motion um
i'm with the committee's indulgence i
wish to bring forward
uh item
tab
11 the water services entities bill to
follow on from that so that would jump
in front of the temporary road closures
just for continuity uh the two subjects
are very similar
so anyone have any
any great
grievance about that
yes council saber
thank you mr chair it was going to be
one of my questions if the notice of
motion was successful
whether or not
that in fact ruled out
council from discussing any further tab
11
because my understanding of joining the
communities for local democracy and
their mou
is that we are signing up that we would
if that motion was successful have
signed up to a
message and policy discipline that would
make it
i would have thought exceptionally
unusual
to then be putting in their own
separate
submission as per a democratic right to
the select committee
for the water services well i guess
we will face that hurdle when we come to
it if it arises
well i'm raising it now as as a
foreshadow
that obviously if the notice of motion
is successful
that would surely be the first thing we
would need to discuss in relation to tab
11.
yes of course but do you have uh
do you have any conclusive evidence that
this is the case i'm foreshadowing that
that discussion would need to be held if
the notice of motion was successful mr
chair and you would ask me to contact
someone from that organisation
to find out if they had a
combined 31 council
submission is that right
the information we have had mr chair
would
lead each of us as councillors to assume
that there is a draft submission from
the communities for local democracy
group okay hello yes uh councillor
councillor crackit then
thank you um cheer i just wanted to
clarify a little bit about that because
i um i too like i'm
very uh
strong on the fact that this council has
put in our submissions both to the water
services entity bill and the proposed
free water reform itself that we are
very clear this council is very clear
that we do not support
a lot of what's going on and what in
this um three waters reform we i don't
think that the
what are we debating here excuse me
we've got
you've got chance to say this uh later
on in both things here so what are you
trying to what i'm trying to say is that
we've been very clear in how this
council feels uncomfortable with a lot
of what is proposed if we
rescind the notice of
the decision that we made with the
council councillor clark's notice of
motion
the mou that we're required to sign to
enter into
the um
communities for local democracy
stops us from having our own voice on
what we want for three waters reform
because they say like the local
government new zealand situation that
when we sign the mou we have to we're
party-whipped we have to go with what
they are
asking us to
and that's concerning for me okay right
taking on board council clark yeah
that's not my understanding of what uh
what counselor sabres just raised my
understanding is that
both the
community for local democracy and local
government new zealand are going to do
submissions to the
water services bill
but that does not preclude a council
regardless of what position they have
from doing their owner
so now i know that there was a
suggestion recently at the mayoral forum
that maybe we might want to do an otago
southland presentation or maybe just a
southern one and the conclusion we came
to is each council had their own right
regardless of where they sit on this
debate about
local democracy group or whether we're
in behind local government new zealand
so i would imagine that too and that's
why i'm sticking with this that council
will be doing its own submission
regardless
of that
okay
let's go
just so that i understand clearly
if we change our position
the
draft that we have at the moment assumes
that we are following along
our previous line where
we're not wholly in favor but we're not
wholly against
uh no excuse me no no so i want to
clarify
if we change our position is that going
to require a redrafting of our
submission because i want to i want to
understand so if you read our session
our draft submission i have have you
read the letter on the 28th
uh september 2010 and i've read that as
well okay well that clearly does not say
we have fifty dollars each way not
clearly says we are not supportive of
the three borders build whatsoever
i don't know where you
got that we were even
halfway between it sorry
your opinion and mine perhaps different
mr chair i defer
yeah no no
i think right i'm going to carry on with
this
enough distractions
so
right we've done the minutes now we're
going to go onto them
sorry
can we have a notice of motion but
but
before we
do the notification
since dan can't speak today i just want
to go over the 10 point proposal
that
the communities for local democracy
do raise
okay
number one the foundation principle
the community property rights and three
waters assets are to be both respected
and meaningful
point two the government should agree to
amend its current reform process
and allow time for the revised approach
to be reflected in draft legislation 0.3
with respect to investment decision
making asset owners should actively seek
to initiate authentic discussions with
manufenua at a local level level that
consider co-design and partnership
arrangements
and that acknowledge and enable
threatii based pathways at a local and
regional level
four in return asset owners agree to
commit to meeting health and
environmental standards once known
within an appropriate time frame point
five
the regulatory framework should specify
a backstop provision that identifies a
set of circumstances which should
justify
future crown intervention if asset owner
was not making acceptable progress
towards meeting those regulatory
requirements
0.6
progress should be reported on annually
by asset owners and be benchmarks
benchmarked across the sector 0.7 to
further incentive incentivize sector
process
a formal process might be established
that requires an asset owner to prepare
a plan that would map out the steps it
proposes
to take to meet the required standards
in a financially viable and
sustainable manner 0.8 a process to
finance and allocate funds to areas that
will require financial assistance be
designed that is national and
application and independently
administered administered accordingly to
objective
and transparent criteria
this is consistent with the
recommendation of the productivity
commission
in 19
2019 november
this point nine the subsidiary subsid
subsidy scheme would be designed to meet
investment shortfalls until such time as
sufficient progress has been made at
which point the scheme will cease and
asset owners will finance matter on a
business as usual approach and the last
point a sector-wide sector best practice
improvement process be created and
membership made compulsory in a similar
manner used to implement successfully
the one network road classification
framework and now one network framework
in the road construction area and
governed by waka katahi and the local
government sector so they are the 10
points
that they raise and without further ado
councillor clark
you have
the right to introduce you'll notice a
motion thank you chair um
i take it that people have read the uh
submission so i won't backtrack over
that
um i think it's important that we have a
level of unease in the community about
three waters some of i guess is what you
might call ill-informed because people
just don't know what's going on and they
tend to listen to
i guess um advice that's not all that
clear but it's clear from my perspective
that we have a level of uh opposition
what dan gordon would have told us had
he been presenting today was he took a
very balanced picture to his community
about
eight or nine months ago on the pluses
and minuses of three waters very similar
to the
letter that was
presented to
the honourable minister
by sir tim
on the 28th of september from this
council
and what resulted from that was 95 of
the people they consulted and and they
got feedback from
literally thousands of ratepayers
was 95 said we don't want to buy this um
thing we want the healthy water we want
the regulator but we think there's
another way of resolving the what's
referred to as under investment
and so i think it's important that we
consider our options here this motion
does not declare that we're going to
walk away from local government new
zealand but it's my view having been
involved all the way through in the last
two years the local government new
zealand uh made a very inappropriate um
very inappropriate call with their heads
of agreement with the department of
internal affairs and basically sold our
advocacy down down the river
and so um i think the report that
michael and others have drafted for us
that
were signed by sir tim has some um
outstanding results in there for us as a
council it clearly shows that over many
decades we've done very very well
in the three-water space
the levels of debt that they quote the
government quotes to frighten us into
getting into this new water entity don't
stack up and all the way through this
report which is quite a long report
there are just whole lots of
misinformation that's come from central
government
i guess the other issue is the issue of
that
if we remain silent and sit in the um
sit in these three waters cluster i
guess and supporting three waters what
wheel in effect will do is two things we
will assume that the promises they give
us
on on three planks that they can
actually deliver so they they say to us
it will be economy of scale
they say to us they'll have enough water
engineers to run the business and
they'll have enough contractor capacity
to get the work done and the dia has
admitted on all three of those that they
can't deliver that
we had a a
an independent assessment of this three
waters issue from morrison low last year
early last year and they were quite
clear on the advice that they gave us at
the very end they said we could easily
opt out and stand alone because our
investment has been appropriate and our
level of debt is very low
and our credit rating is so high that we
can borrow money at phenomenally low
rates of interest so why would we get
into a cluster called the
um
entity d where we will subsidize
councils who haven't invested properly
and and so i've put this to di on many
occasions
and so uh and i never get a straight
answer on that so um
i think it's important that we join an
advocacy group that gives us a voice on
this issue and this issue only you'll
note that the uh the fc group is not
trying to change the freshwater
standards nor is it trying to change the
monitoring agents it needs to be there
to make sure that whoever delivers this
in the future actually delivers it right
but there is another way to resolve what
they see is the under investment
or the levels of debt that you can
afford
to get this work done it doesn't have to
be a sledgehammer for all
and i can tell you from my analysis
that we will cross-subsidize the other
councils in a significant way so it's
all very well to listen to some of our
local colleagues
colleague councils who say yeah they're
very much in favor well of course they
are they've got major problems in their
service delivery area we don't have that
and why should our rate payers pay for
it so i think we should join the group
and ask
the major focus of that group is to ask
government to pause
not to throw it out but just to pause to
reconsider the way to
get find solutions to the problems
and i think the supporting letter that
was sent in september
clearly highlighted that we were not in
favor of three waters
and so that's my comments to the motion
thank you councillor clark of course you
will have the writer reply a couple of
things i want to make
clear is that i will allow each member
to speak once on the topic
and but
questions of relevance are allowed
and as a matter of clarity
and using a mobile device to further the
business of council i have a reply from
dan gordon that says
not at all you are may you are free to
make your own submission and make a
choice if you support c4ld submission we
can't bind another council and wouldn't
try to do so my council is making a
separate submission there we go so that
is the clarity from
the man himself so um can i open it up
and who would like to speak
no second we need a second for the
motion
uh we haven't haven't ended have you
moved to council class i am yeah i'll
move though
okay i will second that
okay so it's on the floor there you go
i see some rustling over there
councillor darren ludlow
thank you chair
um
so keeping an open mind um
on on the subject and i i may arrive at
a conclusion by the time i'm finished i
don't know
um
how long would you like uh how long have
we got
it was probably longer than the standard
10 minutes
um i
looked through the notice of motion um
and and not wanting to discount it
because that wasn't the direction that
that council had tried a preference for
previously
um i contacted one of the um one of the
mayors involved in
c4ld
to to have what was a really useful
discussion i guess my my main concern
was around the potential for such a move
to
[Music]
to undermine
the effectiveness of of local government
new zealand i mean we need
uh an advocacy agency to to move between
us as a collective of councils across
new zealand and central government
if we go back to the letter that we
wrote in september of last year you're
quite right this council is is very
clear
on its opposition to three waters
and and ultimately regardless of how
people want to vote on the notice of
motion
i'm not aware of anybody at the table
who's in support of
what it is that that was that was put
forward
um
you know we've received a large number
of emails from people there's there's
been
pretty clear and active
uh communication from the public not
just locally but nationwide around
opposition to to three waters
i think the salient point that
was raised last year was that
under the the local government act
our job as councillors is is about
looking after what's in our area
the government
is concerned
with brand new zealand
if we're looking at what's best for us
i i think
invercargill city remaining as a
standalone is the best option
for for what we can achieve for our
ratepayers
if is there a need for
drinking water standards and three
waters in general to improve across the
country yeah
yeah i think some areas do
need quite a bit of work
um but perhaps it would have been really
useful if if government had been up
front about that i mean it's like the
ability to opt out
um
i'm still not convinced that that that's
an option
so and and talking to
um
the mere that i did last week i mean
they were very useful in trying to
reassure me around my concerns about
what what the effects on lg and zeta
but then i look at what lgbt
has done and is doing and councillor
clark is quite right you know at the
start of this process i don't think
they represented us well at all
um and i think there's been a pretty
clear message that's that's been sent
around that
round about this time last year july
last year
councils found out about
i guess financial encouragement if you
come on board with with three waters
and what we subsequently find out in
very recent months is that actually only
a portion of that funds is what we're
going to put in up front the rest will
be provided by the entities once they're
established oh well that makes good
sense so these poor entities are going
to have to raise funds to pay councils
for potentially what financial
enticements to join
makes
no sense to me at all
but after acknowledging
the way lgnz is acknowledging the way it
it could perhaps have performed better
not perhaps the it could have performed
better
we've had the governance working group
which i think has managed to
come back with some 44 changes to what
was um
proposed
there is another working group i think
it's the um
rural surprise suppliers
rural services working group that's
coming forward with some another
30 odd
and and you would hope that they get
some traction
with those
that said i still can't see an entity
that covers the entire south island as
being anything near a good decision
when you look at the topographical
diversity
even between us and northern south and
between northern southland and central
otago between central otago and otago
and canterbury and marlborough
we're just not
the same
and something that people come to us for
is
is to look for
local improvement when when there are
issues
and the chances of us being able to get
local improvement when there are
undoubtedly higher priorities in other
areas
for there to be improvements that are
probably frankly more needed
the chances of us having our say is
is not great
so
i'm uncomfortable
with
the potential for the notice of motion
to upset that relationship with
lg nz
but i'm also not
uncomfortable with with that discomfort
and if and if that's what's required
that's
um
a decision we may well make
i guess that i'm saying i'm still open
to
council considering
the option and i'm really keen to hear
what others have to say it's a really
difficult landscape it is unfortunate
when
it has been represented that people who
didn't vote to support this
when it last came before council were
seen as supporters of three waters
or the three waters proposal which was
far from the case
far from it
and
more than just a bit aggravating that it
should have been presented in that way
um so i look forward to the collective
opinions of councillors and helping to
guide me and where we should be
ultimately we want something that's
that's going to drive the greatest
chance to get the change that is going
to be best for us
thank you chair
thank you council ludlow um
looking up to the screen not to have
anyone
else right um
councillor sopher
then miss cook
thank you mr chair
the political reality of where we are at
the moment has moved on a very long way
i feel from the wording of this notice
of motion
which is still talking about advocating
for a solution to the government's three
water reform
the political reality we are now in is
that there has been a report from the
technical working group the governance
working group and the rural supplies
technical working group all of whom have
suggested amendments to the proposals
many of which have been taken on board
and the other political reality is that
the first of three bills
the water services entities bill is
before parliament with a closing date
for submissions of the 22nd of july
we if we pass this motion today would be
passing a motion in a committee
which would need to be ratified by
council at a council meeting
our next council meeting is not
scheduled to take place until after the
22nd of july
we have a proposed sorry can i
correction there please
yeah i just want to clarify the part
about the gratification by council be
happy to have the clarification but at
the present time
we have a very responsible
draft of a submission ourselves with our
own views to take a democratic right for
putting in a submission to the water
services entity bill which is currently
before parliament on which we can
currently have assay
and make invicable city council's
position very clear where it really
matters
in the forming of the legislation for
the first bill of the three
that we know are to be presented that is
the democratic process i am very
committed to invercargill taking its
part in the democratic process
a concern i have with passing at this
very late stage this notice of motion is
that it would undermine the partnership
with lgnz
we have all seen our gnz's proposal for
the
lg nz
submission to the select committee it is
very wide-ranging i suggest in that we
have some points that could be added to
our own draft
such as the regional advisory panels
which would add a great deal to what is
being debated about the community
consultation that can take place
the other thing i am concerned of is if
we pass this notice of motion
that we would be providing a distraction
to the actual work we are interested in
of creating modifications to a bill that
is before parliament as an invicable
city council we are interested in
modifications to a piece of legislation
before a select committee
that is what we should be concentrating
on
not distracting ourselves onto possibly
joining
a community
for local democracy group
which says they have a plan
in their note in their memorandum of
understanding for a continuous campaign
where we we would be signing up to
message and policy discipline we're not
quite clear what that would mean and how
far into the future it would go but
presumably it would it would last for
the time of all three bills and would
distract us from what we want to do
in actually having modifications to the
first water services entity bills
that bill that is value that are
favorable to this council
that is where we should be concentrating
our time
effort
and our support of things that have
already been recommended by the
technical working group the governance
working group and the rural supplies
technical working group
it seems to me that we do not at this
stage
have any benefit to be gained from
belatedly joining a lobby group
when we have lg nz very firmly in court
as they have shown from their own
proposed amendment their proposed
submission
and we ourselves have a very clear path
with our own draft submission which we
can add to and amend with some points
such as i've suggested with the regional
advisory panel
i cannot see
any advantage to us spending fifteen
thousand dollars of our rate payers
money to join
another lobby group
when we when we already have our gnz and
our own submission prepared we have till
the 22nd of july to put in
air democratic input to the water
services entity bill
we will have a democratic right as a
council to put in submissions to the
following two bills
but we have to accept the political
reality that there is a bill before a
select committee
that one way or
another is going to need to be
brought back to parliament
we would suggest in an amended form
we have a chance to input to those
amendments
i do not believe
that we should be distracted
into any late late and last minute
grandstanding on joining another lobby
group
with a different agenda from this
council's own
thank you mr chair
okay just as a matter of clarification
there uh you're incorrect uh
uh this committee has the delegation and
it did in december the 7th to
make that decision
uh if you want to check it it's in the
minutes of the council meeting december
21. thank you for clarifying that that's
okay does not take away from what i have
said no no i thought we better get
procedure right and the other thing i
would just i thought
no i haven't the other thing because of
what you have now said the other thing i
would put in as a question that needs to
be answered today by those who might
advocate that we join this lobby group
group is at what point
does anybody in this water services
entities area
agree that self-regulation has failed
and regulation needs to become a part of
the environment we are looking at for
the future of water services in new
zealand are you talking about tomorrow
are away
i'll leave that to the to the
mover of the motion to answer
okay because everyone knows just clarity
tamara roi is the new
uh crown entity that's been assigned to
take over the control of water quality
it came into power first of july
so
that is the entity that controls water
quality okay
right just make that clear
uh now miss cook
you got to mr
chair um supporting what councillor sopa
said about
the
wisdom or otherwise of spending 15 000
of ratepayers money on joining this
group when we just had a battle royal
a week ago about
the impact on rates of decisions that we
make 15 000 i know
is not a significant increase in our
rates but it is an unbudgeted for
expense
and for those who keep saying about
budgeted expenses and unbudgeted
expenses
this should be a consideration
i
obviously
have a perspective about
entity d and
the area that it covers because it
covers it is the court away over the
people that i belong to
it's not accidental the way that the ntd
water is
defined having said that i'm sitting in
invercargill i've lived here most of my
life and i was born here
i want what is best for us
does that mean i want what is less
good for others no it doesn't
we
are making decisions that represent
the future of our grandchildren and
their grandchildren's grandchildren
not just for today and not just for
tomorrow
i want to be sure that this
decision that we make today
to
join a group that says
that
they want better services local
responsibility sponsors
accountability public ownership and
meaningful manafenua involvement
with an emphasis on the last bit
needs to live up to what it says
because
talking to people in the areas where
some of these people mirrors come from
their mana fenwa engagement has been
appalling
and part of the reason why manafenwa are
upset with them is because of the
service delivery to the areas where
manafenwa live
now
we could say
as i have before at this table
that we live in a position of privilege
we lack our own land we were
disenfranchised in our own area the
council owns more of what was our whenua
than we do
however
we could be those disenfranchised people
who don't have healthy water
who don't have good sewage
who don't have good stormwater
articulation and have been neglected by
their councils
we could be in kennington
or we could be in ottatara
or we could be in myris bosch because
currently we don't provide the same
extent of services there this could be
tuahue
this could be rapaki this could be
kokoda or wherever
it's an accident of fate
or
a colonial decision that means that we
didn't have land here
but would it make it right not to
consult
if you're
going to do manufenua involvement and
you are community for local democracy
and you're wanting to persuade members
of invercargill city who are manifenua
to support this
might you not have reached out and had
conversations with us
we are not hard to find
so on the on the last premise that they
said meaningful manafenua involvement
they have failed this council hasn't
but they have failed
why
would
my fellow councillors my fellow members
of the table are on my i'm not a
counsellor
my fellow table members expect me to
support this
when
by the very definition
the council that i sit and relate with
every day does better
than this group
by every stretch of the imagination
they do better in their manifest
involvement in the amount of funeral
engagement we could be all high we could
be nightcaps
we're not
but are they less because they live
outside our boundary
this
proposal offers better
for them and i think of them every day i
know i sit here for you
but are we not our brother's keepers
should we not actually think of the big
picture because with local government
reforms
our brothers and ohi and nightcaps may
actually be members of our table our
bigger table and in terms of water and
sewage
and the effects that they have on our
environment they are part of our
community because we are part of the
regional council
we have
responsibility for the water quality
that
we actually have flowing
through
the new river street
down the waihoopai stream down the
o'oreite down the makaria
and it flows through the city
all these things have impact on us as
well how do we make change if we don't
open ourselves up to a different way of
working and saying it's not in my takiwa
so therefore i don't have to
worry about it
it comes through our takiwa it makes
water quality in the new river estuary
horrific
not saying we don't contribute to it
but what comes downstream from other
unservices communities or poorly
serviced communities does
i don't know the answer but i do not see
communities for local democracy being
the answer i see this community taking
care of it as being our solution
you mr chair
thank you mrs cook um
right to
is there anyone else like to speak i'm
looking at the screen yes
councillor hummonson
thanks chair
i'm going to start by saying that i'm
disappointed that we're relitigating
this issue again
an issue that was
discussed and decided upon by majority
vote in december last year when we had
full attendance at the meeting
and also disappointed that this
discussion comes with uh
i guess a slight threat of intimidation
by some to say that
this
discussion is going to be public and how
people vote is going to be made public
and you might recall that actually in
december last year the discussion was
also public
and who voted which way was also public
and so i would hope that the fact that
it's nearly an election time wouldn't be
a catalyst for people to change their
their
vote the reality is uh we need the best
chance of being heard and getting the
changes that we want
with three waters and i'm not convinced
that joining the communities for local
democracy is the way to do that as has
been mentioned there's two working
groups so far that are putting forward
recommendations to the government
and one of them has got over 40 changes
already made to the legislation and it's
looking like the second one is going to
have 30 plus recommendations that are
changed in the legislation so that's
something above 70 changes to the
legislation that these working groups
have achieved and at this point in time
i don't see any changes having been made
as a result of the actions of the
communities for local democracy group
so in my opinion i think what people
want or in my experience what people
actually want from us is a rational
approach to this issue
they want
the approach that the majority of
council has already supported
and they want an approach that is using
the system that we have
to get the changes that we need
and so i'm in full support of us
continuing down the path that we already
have
and that includes making a submission as
part of the submission process
and it's already been mentioned a couple
of times just about the mou for the
communities for local democracy and i
just raised two points that um are in
the first page of that
mou
the first in developing and executing
the campaign strategy campaign partners
would agree that message and policy
discipline is important and that any
proposed departure by the individual
partner council from agreed messaging
or policy positions should be discussed
first amongst councils and later on
in section five under basis of
participation it says partner councils
agree to adhere and execute the agreed
campaign strategy now i haven't seen
that campaign strategy
and if a partner council chooses not to
adhere to the campaign strategy it will
first advise the plenary of its
intentions before proceeding with any
actions that is at odds with the
campaign strategy so i would also hate
for us to commit to something that we
don't really know what that strategy
entails or whether our submission as has
been mentioned
is in breach of any of those points
thanks thank you councillor arminson yes
councillor kit
[Music]
thank you mr chairman
i've been part of this council for a
number of years and i've
taken note of what our engineers
and staff have done with our three
waters sewage storm water and
drinking water and we've probably got
one of the best systems in the country
well maintained over decades
and i believe that we shouldn't be
subsidizing other areas that have water
systems
that are either substandard or not up to
scratch
and why should our ratepayers be paying
for fixing problems in other areas i do
support the motion thank you councillor
kit um
right okay but before if that's all from
the floor
um
oh councillor crackit you've been
sitting there so quietly
unusual thing for me
um thank you mr chair
um
i have been really on the fence about
this i really have because i was one of
the people that voted against it in
december last year when it was brought
forward to infrastructure because i
really didn't agree with what was
not all of what was set out in mou
but i've recently been to rural and
provincial and i was delighted to hear
from minister mohota who spoke of course
rural at provincial of course given that
rural provincial was very heavily rural
focused i heard the words it is the
from the minister herself verbatim
because i wrote it down
it is the rural communities who stand to
benefit most from these reforms
so we know that the minister knows that
the government knows that in every way
that we
i mean it's not just um
communities for local democracy that are
saying it's not just ground as well but
saying it
that is many in the community that are
just generally really concerned
that
our legacy assets paid for by this
community for this community
uh being um
we'll end up cross subsidising the rest
of our
brothers and sisters around the region
some of us agree with that some of us
don't um
personally the way that it's proposed
now and i'm extremely supportive of the
letters that we put forward to minister
mahuda because i unless some fantastic
new information comes to light and the
no way of uh supportive of three waters
and will not be like happily supporting
it regardless of the fact that it's
mandated i'm scared that we are losing
those legacy assets and i'm terrified
that we're going to lose our local place
making ability where we can work with
developers and the local um
in our region and or in our communities
to decide that yes we want to invest in
this community to get it up lifted and
get the infrastructure in where we need
it
even though the the government is
forcing this reform and even though i
feel extremely strongly about whether or
not we can be or have to be involved in
three waters
i can't
hand on heart support this notice of
motion either because
nothing is actually going to be achieved
by joining at the 11th hour we're going
to be committing 15 000 to
supporting a group
that actually the government's forcing
the mandate anyway
it's so far through along the political
process
that
we can continue with our submissions and
say what we want
we can continue with them and say what
we want but whether or not like it's
never going to be overturned at this
point this far through the process our
community will just be losing that money
when we just set the rate for no clear
purpose or no clear outcome
so for me even though i was like then
please do do not tell me with the
supportive of three waters
give everything away
brush because it is absolutely not the
case
it's just
if we commit to this it actually can't
achieve us anything this far along the
process
thank you councillor thank you
councillor arnold
thank you mr chair um
i've been interested in listening to
everybody speak so far and um oh
microphone uh closer please um yes been
listening to everybody speak so far and
i sort of
[Music]
was a little bit unsure about things but
the reason my
i i agree with the motion and the reason
i agree with the motion is because i
i still think there's benefits of
lobbying against
the three waters proposals
with a group as opposed to
possibly doing it around a delay we
wrote on the 28th of september was an
excellent letter and it did obviously
say that we
we we didn't support the three waters
and i think that's great too but the way
i see it is the assets here are owned by
us they're owned by our uh they've been
bought by ratepayers over
100 years plus um that's all rate payers
and a billion plus dollars worth of
assets um
and
for us to
pay 15 000 to join this group i think
that might be a very very small cost as
to what the
possible increase that we're going to be
paying for our water water services if
we are
then um you know family has been taken
to prop up other areas services that are
substandard to our own
of course then there's the other thing
of course you know with the um with the
new entity of course you know the 21
councils were six votes i i think that
you know
there's no rep we don't have
representation um of
a huge asset that we've bought over
let's say 100 years plus and that's all
ratepayers that's everybody in the
community so um so i support the motion
because i think the fifteen thousand
dollars cost is going to be a small
small cost as to what we could be
looking at if we uh
if we go down the other path then i
think it is definitely benefits in uh
lobbying with a group
i think local government new zealand did
a disservice when they um off their own
back really as far as i can remember and
understand it uh
they agreed with the government's
proposals without actually reconsulting
the the councils and i say i um i think
it's an internet it's an entity that is
supposed to represent us and i think
they did the wrong thing at that time
and i think the only the only
alternative then is really to form a
another group that um
that'll lobby us
lobby as a group against the proposal i
think i think there's been there's
benefits and numbers
so i am uh for the motion
thank you sarah councillor craig is this
a question um i just want a
clarification
um just because i just would want to
make sure that it's really clear and i
think it's so important that the
community does understand
that um
councillor arnold has just said
we don't sorry that's not a question
what i'm getting there we don't have a
choice to go down
the other path what is the question
it's clarification we do what is your
question then of clarification the the
question of clarification is
is this
three waters reform
being mandated
absolutely yeah yeah you've not been
reading do we have another choice but to
follow what the government is telling us
to do
no
um well
um that is your opinion and i guess the
group that uh councillor clark is asking
us to join uh trying
to reverse their decision so correct
that's what we're doing correct yeah
they're trying to reverse it you could
either sit down and be quiet or
join this group and
make some noise so that's that's i guess
what the purpose of this group is
ah yes council lewis
i've listened obviously with intent on
both sides uh microphone when i don't to
address a microphone i don't want to
address or go over the same points that
so many have made quite eloquently
much has been said about the fifteen
thousand dollars
once one sub fee hopefully would only be
once up for you and that represents
approximately point zero two
percent of a rate increase which is
quite minimal in actual fact to get a
satisfactory debate from the the cell
phone members
to get
a few problems that we've tried to
thresh out here and we've threshed out
various times but to get consensus from
a larger group to discuss all those
problems i think point zero
two percent
plus or minus half a percent
um point zero zero percent
and i think it's worthwhile
i will be voting for animation
right
is this question counselor suffer
it is indeed
uh it refers back to
councillor arnold
councillor arnold pre appeared in what
he said to be saying
that this group communities for local
democracy
was an alternative lobby group that we
were joining an alternative group to
lgnz
and that was a statement not like i
would not like it to be left in the
public mind
no sorry this is not a question sorry
counselor sophomore
i need a clarification i'm not
entertaining
right do i have anyone else wishing to
speak or sort of running there on the
screen no well i'm like ah
was that
lindsay no it is me it is me i'm nervous
as well oh and pania right
oh let's play a good christmas party we
have a gentleman who's going to let you
go first
oh
lindsay
um i just want to actually just say that
i support what counselor sopha
amazon and cricket have actually said as
well as miss [ __ ] um i don't i don't
actually see
there's no benefit i believe in joining
another lovely group and using recruit
money and so
um
understand that uh rural communities
will mostly benefit while she's going to
be great you know and and progressing
our position going forward so
i can't support the notion of notice of
motion in front of us today
thank you
councillor abbott sorry for calling you
lindsay i apologize uh that's no problem
i do answer to that
frequently
um
i i just
it's been an interesting discussion and
i just feel that um the points of
counselor sopha councillor arminstein
um councillor cracker and miss cook and
literally narnia sorry for calling you
have made
are very relevant and
the word mandate keeps coming up in my
mind and the fact that we have
submissions and further ongoing
submissions happening
and
it reminds me sort of the 12th century
king canute when he thought
that he could stop the air tight he knew
he couldn't but he demonstrated that to
the public generally that it wasn't
going to happen and that it was futile
and i think this is futile too
so i am not going to support the notice
of motion
thank you councillor evan okay ah
councillor lush
yeah um counselor nice um
uh retelling of king can you too often
that one has gotten wrong um look good
discussion and i presume everyone's made
up their mind
just i just want to
bring make one point and i think it's
from brian fellow who's the former
economic head of the new zealand herald
when writing about three wars and i
think it's important people know this
if you want and he goes on to state if
you own something that makes you money
or saves you money and that you are free
to sell that that is an asset
if it's only going to cost you money and
more and more each year
that is really a liability and i think a
lot of people talking about three waters
as our assets
but i think probably in any
sense of the term that is not correct
it is a liability and if someone comes
and offers to take a liability off your
hand and maintain it it's like someone
comes around to your house and says
you've got a dishwasher i will
look after maintain replace that
dishwasher for the rest of your life
you'd be a mug to say no so and i also
don't quite know why we're revisiting
this we've also in my short time in
council i've had this discussion this
free discussion and had a vote on it and
the only reason we're back here now
i don't only know i have no idea why we
are back here debating this because the
whole thing's been done and if we
revisit everything again it just makes
council
um incredibly ineffective so i think i
want to change their mind i think it's
important that people know the
difference between an asset and a
liability
okay
um
i think i'm the only one who hasn't
spoken
before councillor clark
look like
no it's okay
um
a couple of things why are we revisiting
this i'll answer that question uh
dunedin um back like last year or it was
last year early this year voted to join
the group and then
their decision was revoked
under controversial circumstances but it
was revoked that opportunity is there
for quite emotive um subjects so
that is democracy so that's why we
revisit things and the day we stopped
doing that
as you must click this goodbye the other
thing is benefit the benefit of joining
the communities for local democracy now
if you look at the next item that i've
brought forward on the agenda
and that's the submission it also
contains the letter from the 28th of
september last year
now that letter speaks strongly it was
so clear and telling denier what we felt
it was eloquently written
by our staff and it was so unambiguous
that you can not read it and come away
saying uh they aren't happy down there
this is not gonna work
did that did they listen to that letter
no no they didn't listen to the letter
i'd love to see where it was file bin 13
or something we're preparing a
submission we're going to send off are
they going to listen to that submission
no they're not going to listen to that
submission at all but i'll tell you what
they're worried about they're worried
about the growth
of communities for local democracy
how do i know that well i tried to get
dan gordon to speak today
wow did that get some interference so i
decided no we won't do that we'll just
keep some harmony here
and uh i've rung around a couple of
other councils and found how did you go
with trying to get your vote across oh
[ __ ] it wasn't easy it was like the
world came down on us
now
can i have that map please
i'm just gonna i'm just going to get up
a map of uh
and it's going to show
that uh in the uh
teal colors as as the current council's
31 councils who
are members of communities for local
democracy
now the benefit of joining well one more
council is going to tell the government
that this is serious
and what the people see in new zealand
wow this organization is growing it's
tangible it's real it's not just a whole
lot of letters going to the minister
it's not just waiting for bills to be
repealed it's not just
farting around a lot of people talk the
talk but no one walks the walk i read
today in the adt
about
south and district council are using big
words
against three waters don't take our
bloody assets do we see them on this
list
no
so if we are going to move on in our
next item and support
the submission
how can we not and honestly support
what we are trying to do here we want to
be heard
the current mechanism of being heard we
aren't being listened to
so by joining this group
it shows the government
we actually care and it shows people
within cargo we care
council clerk
point of order mr chair
a question
were you implying and what you said
that there was direct govern government
interference with you as the chairperson
of this committee no i did not say there
was government i did not mention
government at all
so
any more sorry um
a series of point of orders
understanding orders can actually
um receive the ire of the chairman so i
caution you counsellors
counselor clark you'll write a reply
yeah thank you chair and i'll just work
through the comments that were made
specifically because i think it's
important to address back to my
colleagues um
council ludlow raised some really
interesting points he talked about the
need for us as
ratepayer advocates
to look after our area
and he said that what's up against that
is the brand new zealand which is the
overall scheme
and my response to that i guess would be
is if you want to fix a water problem
right throughout the country then you
should think about using taxpayer money
as opposed to ratepayer money because
then everybody's paying equally what
happens when you have rates in it is
that we will because we've done well
we'll be penalized going forward we will
subsidize the councils around us and in
the south island taking our that haven't
done well and in particular those small
rural areas that are crying out for
further investment
council saper talked about the political
reality well i don't know what political
reality is we live in a world where we
advocate for rape pace
and the dia has said to us this whole
program is built on three platforms
economy of scale at 45 percent
was the first one
morrison low has said in otago southland
that is more like 20 to 25 percent and
that was in our submission to the
minister
second issue is the issue of being able
to recruit and retain water engineers
that is a national and international
problem there are shortage in this area
when i specifically asked
the head of dia what they were going to
do to resolve that
they said i will just take your people
out of council and they'll transfer over
and i said well hang on a minute that's
not the right way to do things because
not all our water engineers will want to
go and work in dunedin or christchurch
they may very well retire or they may
very well go across to the industry
providers who are the people that
actually will do the work the downers of
this world so as i upscale they'll need
water engineers as well
and then their last response is well
maybe we need to talk to the
universities about those three year
degrees so you can work that out how
long it'll be before we upscale enough
of those and then the final issue was
the issue of the industry and new
zealand being able to cope with the
dia's um uptake of extra work which they
said was 200
the industry have said that they can
upscale 20
again i said to the minister about a
year ago so how do you fill that void
will it mean that big metros will get
work done and people living in the ohio
nightcaps areas won't because people
won't want to go that far out they'll be
able to cherry-pick contracts and her
response was
we'll probably need to bring
international players into the country
and i thought that was a damning
indictment on our
thing to be thinking about that as as um
councillor
lewis has said the 15 is a red herring
is such a small amount when you consider
that this council spends roughly 200
million dollars a year
and so having that advocacy is an
important thing
evelyn was quite emotional i'm sorry
councillor i'm sorry reverend evan was
quite a motive about
anthony d
and and again um
it's not our job as representatives of
the right person in cargill to be
considering southam district
or the mckenzie country or anywhere else
we have to do what's right for our our
community
um
and it's uh
it's very easy to say that
i'm wondering she says she wants
[ __ ] involvement and i'm not
opposed to that but that's a long way
different for having co-governance
and so we keep tiptoeing around that
issue
bex i'm sorry
councilman marston talked about uh
relitigating well the reason why we're
re-litigating this is two two real
issues one is that the
government gave us a whole lot of
commitments under the mou and then sold
us down
down the river
and secondly we haven't talked to our
community about it yet so it's important
that we have a voice it's too late to do
the community um consultation but i
believe but the alternative group does
give us a voice
and i'll just
touch on one thing at the very end about
that
um
and i i just
i guess i struggle with counselor
cracker saying what she said last time
that she was very much in support of not
in in
in support of three waters she was keen
on localism
but then says based on fifteen thousand
dollars she potentially votes the other
way
um and the final reflection i'd make was
why would we trust this government and
in particular this this government
minister so here's here's the truth of
it all you will recall back not too long
ago and you were cheering a meeting
chair
that we had a nose emotion up for to do
public consultation and you quite
rightly said at the time no we won't do
that because we don't have the right
information
and at the time the minister and the dia
said
three or four things to us
give us your issues write to us about
your issues i'm not sure we actually got
a response to that but i'm open to be
challenged if we have
two don't consult with your community
yet
three we will give you a
council specific set of criteria that
you can go and talk to the community
about so it'll be specific just in the
cable and we've never got that and don't
worry
if all else fails you can opt out
what
cabinet papers have subsequently
disclosed just two months before giving
us that commitment that already decided
to mandate so they sold us down the
river so why would you trust a
government that does that and we need to
have an alternative mechanism beyond
local government new zealand and as a
final comment
i would reflect
that what i've put up as a no summation
does not undermine local government new
zealand when the three waters issue is
resolved whichever way that goes i would
expect us to be back on a normal footing
with local government new zealand but
what we're saying for them is you had
the chance to advocate you've gotten to
bed with the dia
with the heads of agreement that allowed
for no criticism and you've subsequently
taken funding from dia to help in the
promotion work of three waters which i
find mind-boggling that they would even
do that knowing that 31 of the 67 67
member councils have opted out and over
and above that the ones that have
remained and we're one of them and
dunedin's another
nearly half the members in those
councils are also opposed so it's very
easy for minister mahuta to say well
it's not a majority but if you tallied
up the number of
local body
councillors that were opposed it would
be the majority
thank you
okay
um that is uh has been a
quantum exercise that but it's been well
worthwhile
and now comes um
we've had that moved and seconded
ascendant i'm now going to
put the motion
sorry counselor yes
can we call for i'd like to call for a
division okay uh council clark has
called for a division
so i'm going to put the motion all those
in
favor
in fact i'll go through the
recommendations
um that in fact the recommendation is
that icc
revocate the decision made december 7 21
the infrastructure meaning not to join
the communities for democracy in
accordance with
section
24.3
of standing orders
okay and that icc agreed to become a
partner council for the purpose of
advocating for a different solution to
the government's three waters entity
and an icc commit to the 15 000
partnership membership fee so those
recommendations one two and three are
going to be put all those in favor
please say aye
yeah so can everyone raise their hands
please for the eyes
cheers
counselor louis
councillor clark
number one
scout
and some cute
she's looking towards the screen i'm not
sure
okay this is for the yays so
okay
yeah yeah okay so we've got those so now
i'm going to ask for the nays
and me as well yeah that's nice
okay the motion is lost is defeated
thank you everyone for that
right now we move on to
the water services bill we're moving
that forward
um
who is going to speak to that
michael day
and rhiannon
cameron thank you
thank you chair um i will hand over to
my um staff member rhiannon
who
drafted the submission
kia ora councillors so um
this draft submission has been developed
following a
direction from the chairs of committees
that you were likely to want to submit
on the water services entity bill and
that the basis that which should be used
is the original letter that went to
minister mahuda in september
so
in drafting this we've brought it to
this committee at this time now in order
to follow the advice of local government
new zealand which was the best way to
support engagement across the community
is to provide the submission that
council wishes to make to the water
services entity bill ahead of time
before the july 22nd date in which the
submission would need to be made in
order that those members of the
community that wish to make a submission
themselves understand the position of
this council
so in putting forward this draft
essentially um working with
legal input and input from technical
officers working in the area
essentially used those issues that were
important to you as a council at the
time of the original discussion of the
three waters reform
analyzing the water services entity bill
as it relates to those issues so
one of the councillors i think
councillor sopa mentioned that this is
the first of three bills so
so only some of the issues raised in
that letter are relevant to this bill
particularly so this bill relates to the
structure
of the governance structure for the
water service entities and thus the
issues
that which are most relevant are
ownership representation
the process for divestment
and the
influence which local councils would
have over
ability to influence decision making on
investment and services
so that is the reason for the structure
of the submission and the opportunity
now is for council
or this committee sorry to consider
whether the submission is in line with
the issues that you wish to raise
and then to adopt it
counselor cricket
thank you cheer um
like
we had um i'm really really glad that
you had had the time to speak with dan
to find out whether or not us um
being in line with the
communities for local democracy was
relevant um earlier
however
there's a lot of what they had in some
of the suggestions that um around
local
representation that i think would like
council sopra even said would be good
for us to include in the submission as
well like the addition of local advisory
panels because i'm absolutely terrified
that
uh with this mandate that we're being
you know effectively forced to enter
we're going to lose our local place
making and in the last paragraph or of
this leisure
um or the last few paragraphs of this
letter it does state that councils play
an important role in place making
um and provision of three water
infrastructure is a crucial part of this
for example supporting infrastructure
for new subdivisions so if we have that
ability taken away from us we cannot if
we have a developer say to us we want a
brand new subdivision down rockdale road
to go ahead we no longer have the the
provision or the mandate to turn around
and say yes we support that as a
community um we think it's going to be
fantastic let's go ahead and do it if we
lose that autonomy to
do any major upgrades in our city centre
like redeveloping our streetscapes and
all of the water infrastructure involved
in that how do we
actually have a say when we will have in
the conglomerate of 21 councils that the
entity d will be involved in six seats
only on that
on that current proposed structure so
i would be in favor of supporting what
we have but also expanding it for the
inclusion of those advisory committees
counselors
thanks mr chair i note an address
submission under the representation
that there is reference to the fact that
the bill does make provision under
subpart five for regional advisory
panels and that the wording of that
provision currently is may be
established i would suggest that we
strengthened air submission to say that
that wording should be changed to must
be established
i think around this table there is an
indication of the worth of
the provision that is now in the bill
and i might add that that provision is
in the bill because of the report back
of the working groups
but
i would suggest that our submission
strengthen that so that we actually made
it clear that our submission was that
that word should be must
that we see that is an important part
of the representation issue that we are
very strong on
i also wonder
whether on the regional representative
group themselves
it is worth looking a little bit further
at the lg nz draft submission
there were some paragraphs there about
the regional representation groups that
may
be able to be used to strengthen
what we currently have in our draft
submission
council clerk
yeah just a reflection really on the uh
overall paper that came from staff in
the first instance
i think it's a damning indictment on the
way this has been progressed nationally
and on to us as well
that we are given a time frame on friday
the 22nd to make a submission
and yet in the papers that we've
received to date both government and
from our own staff said that this is a
once in a generation
reform and we've been asked now to
present a paper at such short time frame
i just
it staggers me it really does
and i was interested in what counselor
kraken had to say about concerned over
our ability to
determine investment locally and we will
be shackled by that i've asked internal
affairs specifically and the minister
who will determine the entity's
investment going forward
and the minister and the chief advisor
said well what are you talking about so
okay
will we have an ability to
let's say like you say develop a
subdivision when queenstown lakes
district has massive growth as does
selwyn and while dunedin south has
significant issues as well
and he said you just answered your own
question
counselor
thanks chair
um
following on from what nobby um council
clark said
i wonder if we should use that example
in our
submission
um
that he gave
also following on from councillor's
cracker and sopa wonder if we should
provide some examples
of the things that we have in mind so
around the housing
we've got to puawai
we've tried to
encourage more infield housing we're
trying to grow the number of elderly
houses that we have
and then with respect to this um
[Music]
a second water supply uh we could
mention the drought that we have
just recently had
and the impact that that had on
water restrictions and i guess there's
probably something to be said about
climate change
uh and some of the things that we've
discussed in the workshop yesterday
spring to mind
for that one just to i guess add a bit
more beef to the point and to
demonstrate that
you know these are the things that we
are actually thinking about more
specifically
otherwise i think it's fantastic thank
you very much
because
just want to add one issue to um uh
councillors spoke about there the other
issue for us with our risk going forward
is the issue of our alternate water
supply which we're currently working on
but if that's not completed by 2024
that's the biggest risk that faces us
as a community
if our current water supply comes out of
the reety river is in any way
compromised we have about two or three
days supply for a city this size so will
that be a priority going forward for the
entity and the advice i got was they
weren't committed
they wouldn't come out one way to other
so that's an issue for us
uh misconduct
um yes mr chair um
the
works in progress
would not as my understanding be
affected by this yes we have committed
we have committed rating for that
therefore
well i would like clarification but
having said all that the thing that i
wanted to comment on within this report
to um
submission
is a
phrase on the or a sentence on the
bottom of and i can't see what pages but
it says everyone wants to see improved
health and environmental standards but
the community must be able to afford
them
i
am uncomfortable with us as a council
sending any indication to the government
that
they're um
perhaps concerned about the commitments
of some councils to environmental health
and well-being
is justified we have as
a council are trying and have tried over
many many years of my life to improve
our health and environmental standards
um
the
affordability of this
we have worked within
to indicate that
as a standalone sentence in here i am
really uncomfortable with that and i
don't see that it would make a
significant difference to our submission
were it to be deleted
thank you
okay
councilor abbott are you i didn't see
one of those yellow hands do you want to
speak no i put my hand up and it keeps
going down all the time
[Laughter]
i was about to say once um first of all
i agree with councilman soper that the
word made should be inserted as a must i
agree with that
and just a little point of correction
for councillor arminstein uh we're not
growing elderly houses we're looking to
put elderly housing in perspective for
the outbreak just to make a point and i
do support the recommendation
okay i just want to touch on first thing
is
that ms cook touched on what would
happen in the future for us i asked this
question last year in dunedin the dia
representative who's no longer there
council clark do you remember the
dia's representative name uh alan pragma
yeah mr pragnal i asked it specifically
because we
uh
according with the local government act
we have a 30-year infrastructure plan
and you can understand why because we
invest that far out he said no that
would go
the 30-year plan would disappear and we
would probably look at the next three
years
so that is a major worry because by
statutory law we had to prepare that
plan and for an organization to say now
that plan doesn't matter anymore then
really what are we looking forward to
in the future so that's one thing i mean
the key
the key things that the submission looks
at is prioritization for our for our
work
affordability
and the ownership now if you think a
submission
is actually going to do any good
councillor clark touched on
with the information we got from the dia
last year that we do this we do that
please do this do that and the then
you can opt in or opt out well that was
that was so false
lacking sincerity so how do we move
forward now
with what they're asking us to do
to me this is a rushed submission
process
they're ticking boxes
i appreciate we have to get through the
motion
but they aren't going to listen we
missed our opportunity
i believe in not joining
the group i've already seen my piece
but um i will support the submission
but for anyone to truly believe that
they're going to listen
i think they've been living on another
planet counselor a lot of life
thanks chair um look i think everybody
shares the same pessimism to be
perfectly honest
um but the the thing is
i don't think we can't take the
opportunity to submit
and i also think that we need to speak
at it
you know it
at the at the very least even if
minds at central government are made up
it's our obligation
to say our peace and and to put forward
what our concerns fears
uh and fears are and i think you're
quite right one of the biggest issues
for
indica is that alternative water supply
and and not to have that
progress after having worked on it for a
quiet 20 years
um
presents a real risk
for this community and progress
and
you know we've got to take the
opportunity to to make a submission and
stand before the select committee and
make the point to be of clear conscience
okay that the council outlaw raises a
point about the and that's
recommendation for
does
or does not wish to speak um
right we're looking to the ce here uh
obviously we have to if we do decide on
recommendation for to want to speak we
would then have to choose you could do
that on another day yep another
[Music]
so you may as well
thank you mr chair um
since that very sensible suggestion has
been made and i entirely agree that we
should ask to speak
but there is also nothing to stop us in
the submission for asking that the
hearings by the select committee be in
places other than wellington
and i suggest that there are many
submissions that will ask for other
hearing sites for the select committee
select committees do travel
and i think it would be well worth a
submission making the point that we
would like
a select committee hearing in
invercargill dunedin christchurch
somewhere in the south island that is
outside the so we've come up with hamlet
springs
can i ask a question and councillor sopa
may be able to help me there with a with
a select committee process
if they take it on the road does the
entire select committee go or just a
portion
my experience is that the entire select
committee goes my experience is also
that sometimes has happened with the
waste minimisation bill
some members who for whatever reason are
unable to travel will be substituted by
other members
i have myself been substituted on select
committees that have traveled to other
areas
that is i was the substitute person for
someone who was unable to travel so
generally it would be the whole select
committee or if there is some reason for
which a member
cannot be there then a substitute member
would be appointed well just talking
about that i think it's critical that
you cannot and it's the same with us uh
when do we do deliberations
after uh interviews on um with con
consulting with the public is that you
need that consistency of the same people
hearing the same things otherwise you're
going to have chinese whispers and so
if we need to go to wellington we need
to go to wellington
rather than a sort of semi quasi
committee i think we we would have to do
that otherwise
um
you know i i don't think it's worthwhile
but that's a separate issue
counselor clark
of course it beg is the question uh
who's going to who's going to do the
submission right well i just i talked to
the ceo about that and we would if we do
opt to speak and and recommendation for
we would choose that uh later
uh mr chair it would depend upon the day
and time
uh i think you want to think carefully
about elected member representation and
possibly an officer
okay
ms cook
just a personal observation but i've
been part of submission to a select
committee which travelled and i think
because it was relevant to the place in
which it was being held
it actually was more impactful that when
they come to you they're in your takiwa
so to speak they actually see the
reality of what you are speaking so
asking for a select committee
to um
of such import
to move around is not an unrealistic ask
and has some real merit in terms of how
you would be able to submit in fact you
would not be as limited in numbers as
you were
by flying to wellington
i think
my point was around the consistency and
the people who would be doing the
deliberations
that they had the relevant information
and understood what the other person was
talking about counsellor abbott
yes sir thank you for that i did put my
hand up but it clapped so i'm not sure
what's happening um
i just was going to ask councillor sofa
and you cheer whether the word may and
must were going to be changed and would
it have to be
moved and said fifth recommendation
um
mr chair the item has not yet been moved
so it might be useful if them if there
are
specific points that you wish to have
changed that they are noted at the time
that the items moved because i haven't
heard there
are many points to be changed
so rhiannon have you taking a note of
the those key points
yes
do you want to read them back just
please
so the first one is
suggesting the changing of the wording
around the regional advisory groups to
change the word
may to must be established
and i would just ask whether the
committee wanted to request
that every council should be represented
on the advisory groups because there is
no requirement but my understanding of
this conversation is that is what you
would like to ask for so that would be
the first point
do you want to
just me to go through that yeah look
please speak up if you're not anyone's
not happy with these points so then the
second one is
um councillor sopas recommendation to
review the lgnz draft submission around
the regional representation group itself
in order to strengthen the submission
um
so obviously without having that in
front of me i can't tell you exactly
what that would say but
if it was in line with the conversation
today then we could do that
the third one was around including the
example of place making and whether the
things that were important to this
district would be
important when weighed up against things
like growth in queenstown and so when
the fourth was to include other examples
of things that are important in the
place making space and why council needs
to have
be able to influence decision making on
infrastructure and the examples that
councillor munson raised were things
like the infill housing elderly housing
new subdivision
then the next point was around raising
the importance of the continuation of
the second water supply particularly in
the light of drought and the risks
around climate change
um
which was the supplementary point of the
second
another person raised that as well
and then
there was uh reverend cook's suggestion
around removing or
rewriting the sentence everyone wants to
see improved health and environmental
standards
and the final one was around asking for
hearings to be in places other than
wellington including invercargill
is everyone happy with those
council clubs just one clarification um
on the issue of the big metro's having
too much involvement on investment i
think there's an alternative as well i
think one of the speakers before
mentioned the outlying areas um the very
rural areas in new zealand and i know
naitah and
previous meetings that i've been to in
christchurch have said that they're very
much in favor of allowing those small
communities often with very
large um maori populations that might be
low defiled
to have a significant amount of
investments on and that's fine i mean i
don't disagree with that but when you
consider those two what falls in between
there's a metro's at one area and the
rurals in another area and provincials
like us will be way down the list so i
guess that's a bit of a squeeze for us
so we won't be priority on some of the
needs we may have
given that we've done so well today
does that you
there's nothing rihanna needs to change
for that
council clark i just think when we when
we're talking about the large metros
there's also the very rural areas
are very high right yeah we'll get this
moving along um
we're all happy with that um we don't
need to note it on the screen we've
you've all heard the
ish the the alterations to that so
i'm going to move um
the smoke these recommendations can i
have a second to please counselor skelt
is that with the does wish to speak
right i'm going to get only get to that
i'm going to move actually one two three
and four
um first good thank you for that
please and moving it you need to make it
clear which you are supporting in for oh
sorry um one two and three sorry not
four i'll leave that to later i'll just
i'll get these out of the road uh second
different one two and three thank you
council skill i'm going to put the
motion all those in favor
against that is carried now we're going
to move to recommendation four confirm
where the council does or does not wish
to speak to the select committee on this
matter so i
will do it by
moving those who
wish that we do speak all those in favor
aye against again status
yeah i was going to suggest perhaps that
we extend the motion to include and
request
this
hearing in indica
okay we'll put an additional
additional
bit to that recommendation four
number five number five we're gonna go
number five oh second council of cricket
just speak to that if i can check okay
councillor clark um it it might be more
ambitious i mean i've um presented a
many um select committees in the past
um it's really hard to get them out to
outlying areas it might be more
advantageous if we think about this
issue as an otago southern issue um i
see the chief executives nodding ahead
there because we we've lobby very much
as a group together and it might be
advantageous if if the select committee
came as far as otago and then we could
have more of a regional approach as
opposed to just a southern approach
um yes to see wishes
mr chair i was going to ask if this
motion was successful whether you would
want me to
write to lgnz to ask that they lobby for
this to happen i also thought that you
may wish to
ask me to liaison or you may wish to
liaise with the other councils of otago
and southland to identify a suitable
location for
the select committee and for all of the
uh councils in the otago southland
region to similarly
submit
i think that's a good idea and an
obvious choice to me would be dunedin
they have certainly have the meeting
rooms and everything and the facilities
um so whatever that happens can we just
check that the move or the motion is
comfortable here's the mover of the
motion i'm certainly comfortable with
those changes and is that secondary i'm
also comfortable right okay
in the geographical area
man just comment that it's actually
easier for people from queenstown to get
to mccargo than it is to get to dunedin
we need to not underestimate our
importance in the region
um in terms of access look danine was
look it could be why kikamukow i'm not
really
just leave it at a regional
okay we'll go regional sorry for
mentioning a place so number five
councillor crack at number five
yes
[Music]
that oh goodness what did i say that
council council
seeks or requests to
the select committee
holds a hearing here in southland
in conjunction with
or
potentially in conjunction with our
regional partners and that we also lobby
local government new zealand to
advocate on our behalf
for the same
we need to make this a responsibility of
the chief executive um
sorry you get my intent yes but motion
should be done in the meeting um
councillor crackit
would you be comfortable if it was to be
in the otago
southland region yes
um rather than to make it south and
alone
um
and i think the second part is and asked
the chief executive
and ask the chief executive to liaise
with lgbt
or their support in such a move
and to communicate with regional
partners yeah advocate
also i think would be a
advantageous word to include
advocate to regional partners
for a similar position
as much as i adore hats i believe we're
going to need a t at the start of the
sentence
and you might have a semicolon after
that first regional partner right that's
all agreeable with secondary
yes secondary agrees
okay so we're looking at recommendation
five now and
thank you
[Laughter]
right the next item is temporary road
closures
and uh there's russell here
i just have to take leave of absolute
five minutes
uh thank you members of the public
gallery
council
abbot you're excused
thank you
russell
thanks mr chair
i'd like to say this report has read
um this is really a very early approval
being sought by um for a community event
and that's predominantly around
them needing a motorsport license so
they need to get approval relatively
early
um i do want to just suggest reiterate
that this is being undertaken under the
uh
the local government act which actually
requires that we don't require any
consultation but what we do um expect
from the organizer is that we liaise
with those businesses in those areas so
that the community is supportive of of
those events and those these events have
been run pretty successfully in the past
so i'm happy to receive questions
okay questions counselor not a question
chair um i think we're all familiar with
with the events and the processes have
run in the past which we've missed this
year happy to move the three
recommendations happy to second that
yeah those
three recommendations have been moved
and seconded i'm going to put that
motion all those in favor aye
against that is carried thank you
russell
uh and you can stay around for the
stopping
of
33 bigger street of the road um thanks
mr chair this is a historical issue that
we've identified with the new property
owner and
this is really about how do we manage
the corner splay um and it's this is a
process that we're suggesting is
relatively unusual
and we're looking to
stop that
portion of roads such that that can be
added to the person's lot
on which their current property is
situated so that really gives them some
certainty to be able to actually
complete some building improvement works
this is really just the start of a
process such that the community can be
consulted on that process to stop the
road
okay
the recommendations are that we receive
the report
and approves the commencement of the
consultation can i have someone remove
that being familiar with that part of
south invercargill i'm happy to move
those recommendations and i have a
second down
is there anyone like to comment yes
council lewis no i'm quite every second
though though i know it's been secreted
by a councillor a month
yeah
any comments um i have a question of
um through you mr chair to um mr pearson
how many potential
is this going to open a can of worms for
us because
i'm i'm just thinking of some corner
shops that i've known in the past
um
are there more like this and may this
come up again and should we be actually
um
should we actually even be allowing this
because it's a precedent setting
i'm three years to cheer
we strike
i guess issues such as these land issues
quite regularly there are a number of
small
portions and i think each each actually
needs to be considered on its merit and
i guess the consultation process will
allow that to
be considered rather than necessarily
set a precedent
thank you for that
council lower skier it's probably not
set in presidents i think we had the
same situation the windsor and catholic
in the medical center
of course yeah
okay uh are there any questions or
comments council clark just a quick one
russell that one on your uh aerial shop
there
is the piece that we're interested in is
just in pink is that is that it
that's correct it's a small section on
the corner it's about three meters the
rest is verandah
and it and the piece outside it is a
veranda and verandas are permitted to
extend over the footpath yeah but it's
just actually the corner of the actual
physical building is
in a section of the corners plate yep
that's all good thank you
okay it's removed and seconded i'm going
to put those the motion for those
recommendations all those in favor
against that's carried takes us on to
the parking control by law
and
[Music]
welcome rhiannon
[Laughter]
thank you mr chair uh
councillors
uh there's several amendments being
proposed to the parking control by law
with the development and the city centre
nearing completion the parking maps need
to be updated to reflect what the
streets will look like
when the works are completed there's
also proposed that needed parking
extended to include the section of
fourth street between nith and clyde
streets
there are other minor amendments that
include more formal definitions of bus
stops
and other minor tweaks that the report
covers off on
russell and i have to take any questions
that the councils may have
thank you hayden um
right are there questions regarding the
parking bundle
yes miss cook
um i struggled with maps
so i'm going to ask the question or if i
may mr chair
the
bus routes that have changed
now require bus stops on both sides of
the road and because i live in the area
i'm personally aware that there is not
one in the martin street maitland street
area where there is a bus stop on the
bailey and lower side of the road but
there isn't on the other side of the
road um is this anomaly going to be
addressed in this thing because i
couldn't tell from the maps
so mr chair the the purpose of us
improving the uh i guess that
the wording for the bylaw is to actually
emphasize that the bus stops aren't all
necessarily marked
um so that
we didn't we
didn't want to necessarily
include a map that included all the bus
stops with a physical location
on them
bus stops are also such that you can
actually hail the bus at any location so
there are places where we have formal
bus stops that are on signs and that's
really what we're trying to say where
there's a
sign on a pole
the bus stop is legally six meters
either side of the sign so
so if there's not a bus stop in a
particular place you can just hail a bus
um
i think um also for the response i'm
just aware that at least on a couple of
occasions um drivers have refused to
stop to let passengers off on the
um
[Music]
route
on the the
reverse side of the road because it
isn't a marked stop and it actually is a
difficult
uh area for in terms of parking i'm
mindful that
um a lot of the people who catch the bus
particularly in that area are elderly i
imagine it applies in other areas as
well
and because the constricted nature of
the road there
um
is it possible for some resolution
either we actually train our drivers
better or we actually provide some
alternative solution because i do think
it's actually an issue it may be issue
in other places and should we be
considering it while we're doing this
bylaw process
mr chia guess there's two things one we
we may we may receive submissions from
that that community that require us to
um have another bus stop and certainly
we can work on work with that
bus provider to
look for i guess um improved behaviors
or some more supportive behaviours
okay okay
right for the
questions
um
yes councilman
russell not that i want to prove that i
read the whole by law
but you might want to look at 14.1 your
standing vehicle on roads and rephrase
the
um the
last sentence of that
thank you
okay
we've got um
three recommendations here can i please
have someone move those
thank you councillor arnold seconded
councillor skilt
okay we have the three recommendations
i'm going to put those all those in
favor
against
that's carried it takes us now on to
next by law guidelines
cemeteries and crematorium by law
carolyn
hi
and hayden all right thank you mr chair
um
uh quarter gang councillors so a review
in 2021 highlighted video cemeteries and
commemoratorium bylaw had a lot of
operational information in it and it was
inconsistent with the approach that
other councils uh have with their
by-laws
uh the proposed amendments seek to
remove this operational information and
place it in a set of guidelines
we have completed some pre-engagement
with funeral directors monumental masons
and manufa
and we've incorporated some of their
feedback into these documents
collectively across the bylaw and the
guidelines little was changed um i'll
pass across the carolinas to make more
points at the stage one of the minor
amendments was that we've asked for um
the we've recommended for uniformity and
safety that the
those that erect uh monumental masonry
work are a member of the new zealand
master monumental masons association it
was something that's come up quite
consistently in our meetings with the
funeral directors just for that safety
aspect of the
monuments that are put up in the
cemetery in the premature room areas
council i'd like thanks caroline does
that include um glass and wood monuments
because the term mason just in my mind
signals stone that's all
yes it does thank you
miss [ __ ] hello um so a clarification
through mr chair as i read it
um those
made of materials other than
granite
and
sorry
the other material is escaped me just
right at the minute but it did not
include
limestone and it did not seem to include
wood so i question
um i don't remember the sight of glass
either so i know that in the past there
have been
carved
limestone
monuments placed and i know that there
are glass ones
particularly
in green point i have seen those quite
often
um
this be excluded or
would a family that commissioned such a
piece
have the additional expense of going to
a monumental mason because they
themselves would not have that approval
we have very few monuments put up that
aren't undertaken by the monumental
masons now or have got that sign off
it's like having a master builder just
sign off your work
it's not to exclude any um
material or any work such as you've just
described there
it's very unusual for the monumental
masses to not be involved
um so
i guess there's two
parts is it not
a
a commitment that it isn't an onerous
process a delaying process and that it's
not an expensive process because i think
for
that um
might change people's um ability to do
these things i suppose what i'm um
what these guidelines do they show that
this isn't a major change it's just
formalizing something that
predominantly happens
now you mr chair
right we've got uh councillor abbott
then councillor arnold councillor abbott
i just thank you for that um just like
councillor sacra i'm not trying to prove
that i've read the whole bible um but my
point of interest
i understand free burials and
why
but um
the natural burials says they don't have
a marker i wonder why
it's just that that is the free area
that's that's how they are um designed
and made and occur around the country
that that's just as they are
so there is no
provision for a marker or a stand for
natural burial yeah
okay thank you
okay counselor arnold
um
yeah i'm not too sure i agree with i
think that uh like um
reverend cook said that um you're gonna
end up with a a situation here um and i
must admit like um
my mother's own headstone was built by
uh
a uh
son-in-law
of
cement and stone
and
you know it's yay high um i was
wondering wouldn't it be better to
perhaps have a just a
rule of size perhaps i suppose because i
can see what's going to happen here is
you're going to end up with a bill an
added
cost of probably two to three hundred
dollars it must be for somebody to come
and check the work is what i'm thinking
so you you yeah you there's an extra
layer in here you know when people are
going through a process it's not a
very sad process and
to be honest you know when something's
built that high
there's not much danger i mean if it
falls down they'll probably just rebuild
it again i'd be thinking if you know i
mean there's no danger and no one's
going to sit on it stand on it it's not
going to fall on anybody
i just think maybe it's possibly a step
too far to
to require that
that's
it
daryl do you want to answer that all
steve
yeah thank you mr chair look i think the
key point just to keep in the front of
the minds is this is
proposing to consult on both the
guidelines and the bylaw and get the
community's feedback on this proposal
i think this has been some really good
questions but the proposal is just to
take this uh set of documentation out to
the community for their feedback
just one um thing that i don't think
that they're going to want to cremate
bears b-e-a-r
so it might be a b-i-e-r perhaps
this is also proving that i've read the
document by the way
all right
i'm sorry here
uh counselor arms
go on
ah she was next in lines council clark
do you wish it's just a quick one just
to reinforce what counselor arnold was
saying i i just
don't understand why we need the
bureaucracy layout to be a little bit
heavier if you think of
sam cusack the guy that was quite
different around town and his his
gravestone is quite outstanding and i
hate to think that that
that gets pushed back because some sort
of layer of bureaucracy i mean surely
that
if somebody was proposing for something
a little bit different they'd be able to
consult with the park staff wouldn't
they without having to have a masonry
involvement which comes at a cost
but like you say stephen it will go out
to the community but again the the
people are likely to consult on that or
have someone put are those that have had
a bad experience as opposed to that
might look at it more positively
councillor sopa
thanks mr sorry i'm not just sure what
council councillor arnold meant about
a size
because there are sizes
mentioned
in the
reference to headstones and plaques
you already clarify
yes please i know what i'm saying
size is enough
as opposed to having a the need for a um
a master
more monumental masons association
member to come in and actually sign off
on the
on the on the monument
so i answer your question
yes i'm not sure i agree with the point
because i can see the sense of having
monumental masons involved um
yeah can i ask when this is coming back
the consultation period
oh sorry it comes back to this committee
so the plan is to be
consulting
11 july to 12 august yep and then
i believe it's the
infrastructure services in early
september with the intent to then take
it through to council in late september
okay thank you right so i think we've
got that consultation to come before us
and no doubt um
everyone would have reread it another
couple of times and have some more
questions so
um
i'm gonna
of please someone move the three
recommendations
thank you councillor scott seconded
council of sopa
i'll put the motion all those in favor
against that is carried
that takes us now
to the gifting
and change of building name
and
interrupt
three waters oh three waters better off
running sorry you are dead right
three waters better off funding
rhiannon
again councillors
so um this paper really just outlines
the process for application for the
three waters better off funding which is
allocated to this council as part of the
reform process um just to clarify again
it is not
to be spent on three waters
infrastructure itself but instead on
community infrastructure that you as a
committee believe
is the um
correct infrastructure that would help
this community best going forward across
those three areas that the government
has outlined the first of which is to
build resilience
to climate change and natural hazards
the second to enable housing development
and growth and the third to support
local place making and improvements in
community well-being
so
the discussion that had been had earlier
was taken um
to the tulunaka to seek feedback on
those suggestions so there's an
opportunity now for narunaka to feed
feedback on
those discussions through their mana
whenua representatives before this
committee then makes the final decision
on which project slash projects you wish
to
include in the application
i'll um just note that on the subject of
ternua
which was council's priority project i
have sought feedback from crown
infrastructure who are managing the
feedback sorry the funding process
they believe that on the basis of which
it's outlined it was likely very likely
to meet criteria
there is
a risk which may or may not eventuate
that by seeking this funding through the
better off funding process that may
prejudice
further funding outcomes from other
funding sources such as the dia that is
unknown at this time but it's just an
important factor
to consider
right um
we've got the recommendation is to
receive the the report
okay i'm going to do that because
someone moved that we receive it thank
you councillor lewis seconded councillor
arminson i'm going to put that all those
in favor aye all right
against that so that is carrie that
leaves us with
the decision on what it's going to be
for so we'll just hold that counselor
clark
you're just two points um on on page two
of the report at the top it says
oh sorry council clark reining sorry
just to clarify may not have been clear
enough when outlining the report it's
important to seek to hear the feedback
from the manafenoua representatives
in response to the
to the suggestions from council so
rather than writing that feedback into
the report since both of the manifesto
representatives are here they could
provide that feedback before you then
move on to the decision
it's an important part of this process
right so it's got nothing to do with the
actual project we select it
it does
yes
so
sorry i'll just explain it again so
you um had your initial conversations
about which projects you might like to
include and then
we took that feedback back to manufenua
to the tununaka so that they could
feedback and provide their feedback to
council through this committee so they
have had those conversations and
reverend cook and mrs cook could provide
that feedback now before you then make
the decision
yeah okay i appreciate that but we've
just you've just raised um
concerns
about and were those concerns raised
under the knowledge of the roonaka
they're not concerns it's just feedback
no no but those concerns regarding if
you chose that
uh you said that may impact on other
funding whether runaka aware
of that when you
gave
not of that specific element of
discussion no would that affect um
renuka's decisions or thoughts
um so
mr chair um
um
met with rhiannon
at a normal meeting it wasn't a special
meeting but she came and spoke with us
and consulted with us the conversation
was robust
and their decision was their first
priority was to future proof
housing
um particularly the housing for
older in these able citizens
and their second choice was to offset
some of the cost of te unua particularly
knowing that the storage facility is the
first
um part of that
and needs to progress as soon as
possible
so that was their decision um
the issue of whether or not our decision
would impact on
future funding i don't think is a
decision for the reinika to make it as a
decision for this table
but that's my personal opinion but that
is their clear preference and as the
among eye that is what i am sharing with
you was there a
ratio of the split of the 5.7
um the whole of the um future-proof
housing to be funded first and the
balance to go to unawa so do we know
that amount
uh in here it is 1.92
million for housing okay
right
and so pania
okay
actually um we
we didn't have nano at the table but in
saying that i took my notes to the table
and we had that uh reverse discussion at
our meeting
and um it's even interesting that evan
and i actually haven't caught up but
we were very much in
the same thinking around the
future-proof housing
as well and um and turner was the with
it was the other one we
um
didn't feel that all the funding should
be just going into um
and that we in the future proof housing
was in the forefront of well-being for
our community
thank you thank you
right um
wait two from here council clark yeah
just a couple of issues uh brianna on
page two at the very top it talks about
tribes to money
17.33 million i think it's important
that we clarify that's not free money
from the government like the crunch one
money at the top it's funded by the
entity which means that the entity will
borrow the money give it to us and our
rate pay will subsequently
service the loan that's given to us so
while it's not alone it's a one of the
better words a gift we still have to pay
it back unlike the
money that's in the top area which is a
you take it and you don't pay it back so
it's important to have that
clarification because that was clearly
what was announced by the prime minister
in blenheim
on the issue of the other things
there's two issues for me i guess
one is the issue of the fruit future
proofing the housing
um i understood from michael when he
initially gave me some advice about this
was that
part of the criteria was that we had to
be doing
project work that we already had on the
books as it were that we could bring
forward and if that's not the case and
i'm happy for that to be clarified
so um the funding can be applied to new
projects to projects being expanded or
projects being brought forward so the
preference that for the government is
they they don't want to be funding
existing
projects that are unchanged
okay so if we come down to the issue of
the storage facility which is what we
discussed today at cheers meeting so
just to update my colleagues on there
there is some discussion about what
happens
if our long-term plan is the museum
project
and we know that 10 million dollars of
that's going to be sitting in the in the
storage facility what happens if if the
government doesn't allow for that to be
targeted towards the museum towards the
storage facility because one of the
issues that michael also gave us advice
on was this is a one bit only situation
if you don't get it right you might not
get another bite of the cherry as it
were
so through you check that i've clarified
it as not a one-bed only situation if we
are unsuccessful we can apply again
and secondly it goes to the whole
project
not to a particular stage
i'm okay with it thank you does there
anything else you wanted to add
michael yourself cheer um just to
clarify that we have sought clarity in
relation to that one bit approach and
that's where um that new advice has come
through um the initial vice was that it
was going to be one approach but we have
now got
further advice that we can go in and
build for more from that perspective
and the other aspect in relation to
existing projects um my advice was
around anything that was existing in the
long term plan
you had to change the project in some
nature so it was to bring it forward
could it be one of your projects you
couldn't fund the existing projects in
in the long term plan annual plan is
different so anything that was new into
your annual plan is a new project
so
so on the issue of future proofing the
housing
is that compliant with a criteria okay
that's fine excellent thank
you council server
thanks mr chia i just had um a question
which you two might be able to clarify
in putting forward to inua
rather than any of the others it seems
to me we know te inua has some other
funding sources we could apply to
that may or may not be affected if we're
successful in this one
how about the other projects
i mean i totally agree that the
future-proofing housing is
is being indicated as a priority but the
other projects that are listed there
have we got other funding sources
if we don't put them into this
particular
bid
so there is potential
for the cycling infrastructure that
potentially you could make applications
through various waka katahi funding
that's allocated for certain things
they would require co-funding for which
there is not yet any co-funding in the
budget
um
i am not aware of funding sources that
are available for the other four
projects
michael whether you may
be
yeah through yourself chair there there
is
opportunities and most of the projects
to seek other uh funding sources as we
um always do in relation to these
um
but none that would cover the full
breadth of the project in relation to
these
um so council would have the lines here
in relation to most of the other
projects
and when when you're saying
seek as we always do are you referring
to the local funders like
cetos and
so forth
uh through yourself chair no we would go
wider than that and seek ministry
funding as well for all of the different
funding sources here
okay thank you
council clay
just one final comment and i think was
raised before um boriannon about the
strategic risk that we have if we put
too much money into the museum project
that we will limit our capacity in that
area
um it might from my view i think it'd be
wiser to for us to do the um
the housing issue then do the cctv and
the likes and then push the remainder
into the
into the museum project because we've
got better ability to attract funds in
that area people are more likely to
contribute to a new museum than they
would be potentially to a cctv project
and it was interesting the meeting at
you and i both attended recently
about the cctv was has become a really
important issue for the inner city
retailers
and so the sooner we get i'll get there
done the better
well not only was it in the city yet
actually uh stretched out further and uh
it was quite obvious
so
yeah look um
what's the best way forward to uh choose
this we've got the ewe perspective i
really appreciate that oh sorry alex was
going to speak
yeah counselor cricket
oh slipping
um
[Music]
don't worry about it it's all right i
don't think it's material
counselor arnold did you want to speak
as well no no no not at the moment
okay so what we've had is um i think
everyone
i think
this is my take on it it's quite heavy
with the housing
one um and then that leaves the
remainder to either
sorry council cricket um
i'm really sorry i am going to have to
um speak out against this
part of the reason why uh we've been
given the better off funding and i've
said this before and i'm sorry i'm a
stickler for consistency sometimes um
we're
we've been giving this lump of money
this cash
in exchange for
what effectively buying in or a bribe or
whatever you want to call it for
three waters
free waters was collected for the
community by the community it's a legacy
issue i was sorry a legacy um acetyl
liability in such case
um
i am really uncomfortable with using the
funding that has been given to us for
everyone on a small section of the
community
that is not what the funding is for the
funding in my mind needs to go to
another asset or liability
whatever way you want to look at it
another asset that is whole of community
benefit rather than a small sector so
i'm still heavily in favor of the money
going towards te o noa
thank you
but just just for clarity here um
am i right in thinking that
the people who
use our housing are part of our
community and that we are responsible
council has a responsibility for the
well-being a citizen here well-being of
community i'm not sure is that mr
rhiannon does that
meet the classification the whole of
community no no i didn't say a whole lot
of community it's community well-being
the projects listed all in our
understanding at this point without
seeking further advice on from crown
infrastructure meet the criteria of the
funding
in in the sense in the way that it's
written by central government the
question that councillor crackit is
raising may well be something that you
as a council support but is separate to
the criteria being laid by the
government so how specific we want to be
for the community council clerk yeah
in opposition to what uh councillor
craig has just said i mean we had a lot
of feedback last year about the state of
our our units
significant feedback about it and and
while it's saying there's only a few
people get advantage from it you could
argue that people in north of mexico or
people who know total people in bluff
are not going to get any any any direct
impact from cctv either but the issue is
regardless of who gets the benefit
the council will still pay
it's still a rate payer issue isn't it
if we upgrade those units that doesn't
fall directly on the people that are
using the units it's a an overall
um
rate impact for all of us right i'm
going to
counsel that loan then back to
councillor thanks chair um
i guess at council we've known
for quite some time that the housing
stock
needs upgraded um but our approach to it
has been very
conservative
in the way that we've accelerated it
i find the the feedback that we've had
at this meeting about the priority that
needs to be given
interesting and useful
guess we want to get to the point where
the housing stock is
is
good relevant usable
to uh to code
and the quickest way to do that is with
unplanned money obviously there's a lot
of community interest in
seeing tienue advanced as well
um but not everybody goes to a museum
and art gallery either
and i think we've got an opportunity to
get that housing stock up to standard
and keep it maintained which will be
eventually at a lower cost then
you know i can i can live with that
point
sorry council cricket
thank you mr chair um
we spent a lot of time looking at our
housing and developing a model in which
the
units ended up paying for themselves
because we
we did a whole lot of consultation and
the consultation from the community was
absolutely yes we should be investing in
it
but not
like it should be self-funding not at
the cost of the rate pay a dollar
this i think goes would go against that
again and like i said
the 194 units that we have for
vulnerable people i absolutely get it i
understand why we're involved in
um
older and vulnerable people and housing
however it's the
what about the little lady at pomona
street that's also one of our ratepayers
but doesn't happen to be in one of the
units
what about what about the hundreds of
other
pensioners and rate-paying invercargill
citizens
that just don't happen to be in one of
the units
how do they benefit okay no no that's
point made i'm going to shut this down
we're going to actually make a decision
after councillor munson's back
thanks chair
um
i'm just wondering is if this is a
situation where we need some more
information before we make a set
recommendation
given that
we need 11 million dollars of external
funding
for te una
so
we might be better off to get the full
five million dollars from this for that
if that means we can't get any funding
from anywhere else from the government
or
it might be that we can do both and that
there is another government fund
available so are we better off to have
it as a
um you know can we do some more work
funding out with more certainty can we
still get mch funding for example for
the museum
and if not
then
you know set the path then
okay look i i think it's been debated
quite well enough rhiannon wins the
deadline for this decision
deadline is in september okay we've got
time
mm-hmm
all i would do is is that if you are
going to include alternative projects
alongside tenure they need work to prep
them up so although that actual
submission date is a while away we
actually there's a lot of work to prep
the application
so um
a decision today would be useful okay
that's additional to those projects that
you've listed highlighted these i'm
talking about all the other projects
apart from ternua right
council's help
mr chair to help move it on i'm i'm
quite happy that we move
um the two projects the future-proof
housing and tenure as the two projects
we prioritize for this application
i'll move that way
okay you've got a choice for three
seconds mr chair right we've got someone
moved it and we've got a secondary so
i'm actually going to
test that motion
right all those in favor of the
sort of amend yeah we have to amend um
so the uh
future proof housing is 1.92
million and then do we need to we'll
just change it to the
confirm the inclusion of te anua within
the funding application
alongside
the housing the future
yeah the future-proof housing
well the future of housing is number one
yeah so
alongside tiana being alongside it
implies that the future proof housing is
number one
yes
mr chair could we add a note around um
the other
uh looking into the funding situation or
something like that um
to provide that flexibility
investigate if accepting better off
funding will preclude us from
uh applying for additional funding yeah
other additional funding
just a note
did rhiannon have we noted that did you
didn't have a conclusive answer did you
we are doing that but we just do not
have a conclusive answer on my question
okay so would it be helpful if we
um put this if we if we made a
recommendation to council that came back
in a suitable time and you worked on
this
um say that it'd be useful to understand
what you were seeking to achieve by that
mr chair i hear rhiannon saying that
if the table is of the view that housing
is first in tayanura is second
then that's what she needs to work on
but there is a portion of it to to that
may affect our future in
in this maybe this helps in the
situation that the crown infrastructure
advised us that if you got the three
point whatever million is left from
after you've done housing if you had
that from better off funding that would
mean you could not get funding from
other sources then we would certainly
come back to you at that point and
recommend you actually need to proceed
in a different direction that is not the
indication we've had at this point but
if that eventuates would certainly bring
that back to this table
could we suggest that there's a report
to the august meeting
we're adopting this right here and now
yeah sorry council clark um
just
just to help with my recall i think when
we were looking at the different options
for the museum
the option we select was about 11
million short of what we needed
is nodding so if you if we get a
significant chunk of this
and we know that we've got five million
dollars sitting in ctos
i don't know whether anybody's asked but
i've had more than one party advisors
that it's sitting there
that we are not a long way short of what
we actually need to be
it's not a huge gap to fill
mr chair i met with the major funders
recently and the feedback i had was that
any expectation
was presumptuous
and the
point that i think rhiannon's making is
that the
funding may well have come from other
sources
from the dia or the ministry of culture
and heritage so you may have
forgotten an opportunity for three
million dollars in something else
in the instance i think that perhaps you
could ask for an oral update
at your next committee meeting that your
preferences for tayanua
if it does not prejudice your other
funding chances
and given the work to be done that that
proceeds and we ask rhiannon to give an
oral update at the next committee
yeah like i'd like to get some clarity
around this funding from the cultural
heritage now
i'm over the understanding that this
could be quite significant even up to a
third of the project am i am i
completely off track or has this been
done before in other parts of the
country mr chair i can tell you the
ministry of culture and heritage won't
have anything like a third of the
project available to us
you may recall when you were looking at
museum options that
mr giblin referred to work that had been
done to see what the
likelihood was of getting government
money
and it would be
modest i think would be the best term as
a percentage
and uh i
i'm aware that the sergeant gallery and
wanganui and the rotorua museum are both
currently seeking more funding as a
result of their projects going over
budget it would be unusual to get even
double figures okay considering now
what i'm where i'm coming from is the
understanding that we have never replied
before
to this particular entity for
significant funding now other other
um towns have
and they've got it so are we
um eligible in that sense we're not
adding this is not a cost overrun or
anything this is a major one-off project
that we're doing we've been waiting for
a while it's finally come
where are we because we really need to
know what we're asking for council
adelaide
we're eligible chair but it's around the
availability of funding from that
organisation if we round back the clock
10 years there might have been a greater
amount that they could have provided but
it's all around timing and how much
pressure they've got from from other
projects
if we applied in two years from now
again it might be a different story we
don't know there's there's risks with
with each
time period for application
look we've got to move forward on this
um
we've we've had uh mover in the
secondary that we are going to um
uh
to
the future proof housing and that takes
the full amount of 1.92 and the
remainder
going to turn newer
without anything dramatically happening
uh before we
apply or we apply and can change the
application if we get that information
right so it's been moved and seconded
i'm going to put the motion all those in
favor
aye against
thank you mr chair it's not identified
who the mover and the secondary
i thought it was the mover was myself
yes but there were three of us that
offered a second
girl
you haven't got it on the screen that's
what
yeah
councillor abbott was recording that's
right thank you mr g can i just suggest
the oral update
is a is a reasonable way to proceed at
our next meeting
rhiannon how would you like to deal with
this
i can certainly provide an update i
don't think we need a resolution
malavika will record it in a minute so
that it is picked up right
sorry i'm going to have to apologize and
leave as i'm doing the leadership
academy engagements at toto tonight
i will allow you thank you very much
right
now
we are at the gifting and change of
building name
and speaking to that is
i'm happy to speak to that mr chair
um counselors will take the report has
read uh
noted that we've been gifted a name from
the walhope
and there are three options presented
and we're seeking approval to change the
name to tihamaki's civic building
i hope you take any questions
okay the recommendations we received the
report so can i move that
secondary and put the motion all those
in favor
all right
carrie so
cheer can we thank the roonaka for the
gift
of the civic building we note the gifted
names for the meeting rooms
and recommends the uh this all occurs
on the 12th
of august right and the formal just to
get it right that the formalities around
um
the gifting of the name to save this
civic building
how would that occur um obviously on the
12th of august
after 12th are we having uh
because obviously room names are
different when the room opens
we can do that but with the building it
is
yeah um
mr chair that good question that the
process is actually that we've received
the gifted name from the roonaka
and this will then go towards we'll do
the back office functions of changing
the
uh the title and this will go on the
plans for the um for the building
project
uh we're happy to if you wish to suggest
us we're happy to work with the roonakas
as to
an appropriate celebration at the time
possibly related to the building
and fitting into the building project
um but i equally happy to take any other
questions on that or guidance
initiated the name we did consult with
our about it so it's not
it's not because we're mindful that this
is the principal
city building
um
that
are part of the city and we didn't do it
without talking to them so just to make
that point of clarification in case
somebody further down the line ever says
that we didn't we did
as for the process we will work with um
the um
leadership team and the ceo to make sure
that that
meets both parties needs and
um as it happens and to clarify that the
meeting room names will not be settled
until the configuration of the building
is final because it would be really
silly to name something that ceases to
exist in
that's fine councillor clark
just a couple of issues uh steve on
pnix2 which is the list of the names i
see the first
four actually referred to as the ground
floor but
i've assumed that's meant to be the
first floor
if we were on the first walk but we made
it just to type i'd just say that yeah
thank you
so that you know i have read the notes
the other the other options we've got
there is another potential option well
i couldn't let everyone get in on that
one
we talk about having the status quo
which is european names we talk about
having so many terrier names
or a combination of both
one of the things i've been thinking is
could we have a combination that goes
beyond that so our meeting rooms could
quite rightly be just tourio nothing
else but the i guess the more important
names which is the debating chamber and
the name of the building could have the
dual names i don't have any preference
of which goes first i mean
quite ever quite happy to have teriyo
first
but that could be another an option for
potentially
yes uh through you mr chair look i think
that would uh that's common in a number
of other facilities
where there is
the english
naming they don't necessarily need to be
a direct translation council chambers
doesn't translate to what we proposed
here
so that could be one way if you wish it
direct the team we could look at that
we're way behind
if you look into the government sector
and you look in education and preschools
and places like that they started off 20
or 30 years ago with having the green
room and the blue room and the red room
and now they've got torreo and trio only
which promotes the language but i just
think on those two issues of the outside
of the building where you do give us an
option of having jewel in the debating
chamber it could be an option for two
there i think as a transitional thing
marcus um yeah look just um
love the name just with the gifted room
names and i'm curious i'm not quite sure
the protocol who i addressed with us
whether it's you
reverend cook but the name weka for the
ground for the first floor
how relevant is that to southland
oh absolutely
because they were the original chickens
um
absolutely they're all over our titi
islands and um everywhere we took them
over to the easterly islands that we'd
have
birds too
however it's relevance to being the
council chamber i actually have to say
that some of these names predate my
participation in this conversation
weka would not have been my first choice
for the council chamber but
we can discuss this as we go forward
because i don't think these are graven
in stone if we decide that
um
you want to bring um something else to
prominence that fits within the spectrum
of names we can
very easily accommodate that
um
given some of what we've been up to kaka
is what springs to mind
oh
no not kaka is in
kaka is in the noisy chattering parrot
[Laughter]
i am sorry i know it's getting late but
really
i lost it thank you
i was just going to say since we've
actually passed the recommendation
can we just have a
note in the minutes that says we're
actually going to thank the roonaka
please and continue to discuss the
implementation of the recommendation
which covers everything that has been
said since
it
so in recommendation three would that be
note and thank
the gifting of those names can we
include them there
yeah i want to put it in a
recommendation
and thank you
and something like that no note anything
and continue the discussions on the
implementation is what i'm getting at
because we've just much discussion about
the implementation and the further
discussion about the possibility of
slightly amended names yeah so
we've passed the recommendations let's
just have a note that discussion will be
ongoing
yeah we haven't passed anything yet
um oh have we not no no no we haven't we
haven't had a move
yeah
just making sure we get the uh
recommendation correct for the
no
gifted name for the building i think it
would be
give the name of the bill for the
for the building and meeting rooms and
continue the discussion on
implementation
do we really need that as well the
continuation i think that's
um the way um miss cook spoke um
it would just it's it's it's open though
you know
i don't think we're setting anything are
we
with this
oh well we have time mr chair because um
it cannot happen until after completing
nominations so we've got six weeks
three years chair look i think um the
key tonight is that we have agreed on
the building name which was the one that
we're seeking your approval through the
paper we've talked about we can't land
the building room names until we've
actually landed the building design
and i'm proposing that we will just keep
we'll bring that back to you once we've
got a design that has been finalized
that we can show you what the proposed
names are which implies we will continue
working on it
i don't know if we need to put that into
the recommendation and if the council
chamber does need a different name then
and that would come at that time
right is everyone happy with that
okay okay so council clark yeah just a
comment steve made them um
you talked about the design
of the building
my understanding is from the finance
team that six hundred thousand will be
spent in the next next fiscal year
on an update of that building is that
what you're referring to or is it beyond
that
um i'm looking at
mr day to see if he can answer that in
terms of the time frame and the program
of works we've got planned for
the building
um
[Music]
michael
thank you through yourself chair um
currently the project is still in its
investigation stage um
for initial design um side of it so the
600 is in relation to that aspect they
haven't got
into any of the construction aspects at
this particular stage because they're
still trying to finalize design and
and scope which will need to come back
to council
that will follow on to the uh
implementation phase so they're still
working towards what's in the
uh ltp and annual plan but as i say it
still needs to come back to council
okay just one point to clarify with that
chair sorry be positioned on this so
the implementation phase does not
impact into the next financial year
yes yes councillor that is my
understanding the 600 is all about the
investigation stage and design phase i'm
just double checking that in my head but
you say that's correct that's fine thank
you
okay
all right we're going to move on we've
got those final three
recommendations
um can i have someone it's all nicely
clear for everyone can i have someone
move those please
uh
councillor ludlow miss cook i'm going to
put the motion all those in favor
against that is carried um and that now
takes us to the end i know it doesn't it
takes us to the activity report
which
steve is speaking to
thank you mr chair um
colleague mr mccoy is gonna uh talk
briefly about splash palace and uh
between michael and i we can also deal
with the infrastructure
report
good evening all as tempted as i am to
read the report word for word at 5 45.
so the highlight here for splash palace
is we're seeing a bit of a recovery a
bit of a return to normal it's in the
right trajectory
you'll be aware that we're open this
week with some improvements made to the
place and that will extend through to
the
cafe and front of house sort of layout
so that should actually help businesses
as well so
that combined with a um upcoming promo
or current promotion uh it's looking in
a good
good position right now
thank you anything to have steve look
just probably two points tonight one
around the uh the ongoing efforts of the
parks team at costello palm trek and
community planting down i don't know if
you've been around there but the end
result is looking amazing
and so
congratulations to the team there
also just a note in regards to some of
our
partnership work around the water
treatment and the team
uh
benefited quite a lot from a partnership
with dunedin city council recently
around
maintaining
some of our fluoridation and you're
really pleased about our partnership
but happy to take any questions
or pass to michael for a quick overview
of his areas
um through softchair i just want to give
the opportunity to russell pearson to
give you a very quick update on the
progress in relation to
streetscapes in lieu of the ico farmers
opening it's not not in the activity
report but i thought it was printed to
as part of that
um because it is a fluctuating uh state
of affairs in relation to that right at
the moment
okay russell
sheriff's right yeah speak up yeah no
you're good you might need a mic
come and sit between mr ludlow and
ms
thanks mr chair um the street project is
busily working towards the i guess the
14th of next of this month so it's only
a few days away that where we actually
need to have
pedestrian access from s street to the
new development
um
i guess that what we're seeing are the
contracting teams working through some i
guess a whole range of issues that we've
we faced together with them how we
coordinate but
we are being relatively successful but i
guess the thing we really want to make
sure that everybody's aware is that we
plan to have the footpath on the south
side outside the new development pretty
much complete but the gardens and those
sorts of areas are still things we'll
have to finish and plant off and the
footpath on the north side is an area
where we're still working if you've been
in there recently you'll have seen how
we've progressively working down the
street and i guess that'll continue over
those next few weeks so on the
13th and 14th which is the planned
opening we all have um
accessible pedestrian access from the
north and so south sides of the street
to the new new development um which i
guess is our target
we won't be finished but we'll still
have to do some more paving down the
middle of the street which will take a
period of time but all through that time
we'll actually have good open access
my understanding of the opening is that
the the car parks and bits and pieces
where people will be going through so
we're trying to make sure that people
will be able to come out of that
development and i guess spread out into
the rest of the city centre and actually
um go to the shops that have been
hanging out for such a long time on the
north side through through the situation
so there's lots to do still we're still
pretty much on target but the teams are
working really hard to get it ready
for next week
right and taste street side the car park
entrance
that's all
the taste street side has actually been
completed by icl
right
okay
right any council clerk you were asking
something
in relation to the gostilo park steve
um one about signage to recognize that
if we could have an update somewhere
online about what's proposed here and
the other issue is it would be helpful
to know what the overall cost was i know
how much
derek his legacy has given
would be helpful to know because um
there are pushes from other sectors in
the community to have
this sort of a facility safe routes they
can sell city
so it's part of it you know staying
alive or keeping active or whatever you
want to call it it's not a huge cost of
that thing
and very highly used to know tower
you missed the chair we can uh bring
that update back through the next
activities report yep that'd be helpful
thinking
thanks mr chair um just in in particular
relation to the southern times story
today about the dental issue in
invercargill i just want to pay
particular compliments to dunedin city
council for coming through with
two tons of fluoride it is
a very good example of cooperation in
the region on water and waste sector
issues and very pertinent to health
issues at the moment
okay
any uh
for the comments questions right it's a
simple recommendation that we received
the report i'm going to move that to
either secondary counselor
amundsen and co seconded by council
rabbit i'll put the motion all those in
favor all right
yes is carried
now we need to move into public excluded
mr chair i've had a look at the minutes
and i've looked at the previous minutes
these are literally minutes that are
accepting minutes from the last meeting
so there's actually no content
okay you know what i mean so we could
probably do it in public
um since that responsibility falls on
the new ceo it's am i right and i'm
happy to move we accept the minute okay
and i'm happy to second i'll put that
motion then all this in favor
i would like to hear what mr day has to
say
through yourself chair by
putting those minutes into public you
will make the whole minutes public
that's what i thought i thought there
was a back a back track or ball through
that
i've heard that before but i i was
listening to council amazon's reasoning
it sounded pretty good
but there's actually no content to the
minutes except approving the minutes
from the previous meeting but does it
make
the previous but those minutes do
contain so
looking before the last meeting yeah to
remove all doubts i'm going to move that
we're going to pe it's been seconded put
the emotional favor hi
you
you